Hello everyone.
Welcome to the toxic Google.
I'm Kevin Belkin.
Today we have Mr. George Miller,
writer,
director and producer of Mad Max fury road.
[inaudible].
So you were turning to the franchise that you started decades ago.
So what was that like and in getting this,
uh,
written,
produced and filmed?
Well,
it was a,
an epic saga in itself in that,
uh,
it was,
greenlit three times and fill down twice.
Uh,
and we eventually got to make the movie.
Um,
uh,
eh,
eventually,
the first thing that,
that sort of brought it down was nine 11.
We were about to shoot and,
um,
uh,
suddenly a budget,
Australian dollar dropped by about 25 to 70% of the night.
So we regrouped.
I went on to happy feet.
Uh,
we,
we recast half a decade later and,
um,
eh,
Eh,
with,
from Mel Gibson's a Tom Hardy and then Shelly [inaudible]
and,
uh,
we were about to shoot in,
in the outback of Australia and massive rains came and turned the flat red earth
into a flower garden and,
uh,
the salt lakes into it,
into marshland.
And,
uh,
so we had to wait another 18 months and eventually it didn't dry out enough.
So he had to get to the southwest coast of,
of,
of Africa.
There may be a way it never rains,
eventually.
Got To shoot the movie.
And so,
uh,
between 2001 when it was first green lit to 2013 when you started shooting,
what,
what changes were there in the script?
Um,
or in the story,
this script,
the script didn't change much.
The,
we basically boarded the movie very,
very early on and which is a great tool to help everyone sort of,
uh,
mount the production and the work through the logistics and so on.
Uh,
so didn't really change a lot what the two things obviously costs change.
And,
uh,
but the biggest thing that changed was the technology things that we might've
done a decade ago.
Uh,
w w w might have,
sorry,
the things we could do a decade later,
we couldn't have done a dickhead.
Got The cameras.
We're much more agile.
Um,
we initially were going to shoot native Stereo Three d,
uh,
we built small cameras,
but we could build six of them.
And we suddenly thought,
wait a minute,
conversion to three D is there much,
much better.
It was,
uh,
a h he goes by the,
everyone's getting much,
much better at it.
And so we decided to go straight digital to two d cameras and then post convert.
And they're really good decision.
We,
you know,
put,
put cameras in dangerous places and uh,
we read quite a few,
but they were relatively cheap cameras and uh,
eh,
not the expensive ones,
but uh,
so we couldn't have done that.
And then we had things like edge,
the edge arm,
which is an amazing four wheel drive with a big crane on it.
And then a three headed based,
which was basically a stunt driver,
great stunt driver,
a a grip crane grip,
working toggles and moving the crane can move anywhere.
And an operator,
a camera operator,
zoom,
Pan Tilt,
and me sitting watching a screen.
And it was,
it was,
it was like being in a living,
um,
video game.
It was amazing that Cameron could go,
you could right down into the dust and then swoop up across tires of a war egg
right into an actor's face.
And it just gave the movie a really big kinetic energy that we would,
would not have been able to get without that tool.
So,
so those things change.
Plus I think audiences changed.
We were getting were speed reading movies now.
So we,
we,
we can,
movies are getting many more,
many more cuts in them than they did in the past.
Um,
I,
someone told me recently that the first Jurassic Park had about 950 shots.
Uh,
uh,
and I'm sure the last one where I've had two or three times more than that.
Um,
red wire back in 1981 had 1200 shots and this movie a little longer,
but it had a 2,800 shots.
So things are getting fast.
Yeah.
And yeah,
so you're talking about technology.
I mean,
the movies crazy in the best of ways.
it's a huge adrenaline ride and it's insane and,
but you really use a lot of practical,
you shot on location.
So a lot of it,
it wasn't green screen and it wasn't,
a lot of,
it was real stunts.
And you actually had Tom Hardy up on that scene where he's flipping back and
forth and the pole and everything.
So can you talk about mixing in practical stunts and real sets and real
locations versus using the crutches CG?
Well,
it,
this film doesn't defy the laws of physics.
You know,
there's no spacecraft.
There's no,
uh,
it's,
it's grounded.
Uh,
so we,
uh,
we,
it's real people,
real people,
real vehicles colliding in a real desert.
And it doesn't make it sense to do it.
See g when you can do it for real,
it's more logistically,
it's difficult.
The logistics,
you know,
particularly when you go to a far remote location,
uh,
because it's like a military exercise,
but particularly when you're working in,
in the dust and the car rolls and the dust simulations are great,
but you can never quite simulated,
uh,
Eh,
you know,
the real thing is much more interesting.
And,
and so a principal was let's do it old school and then augment it.
Uh,
should we need to,
uh,
with,
with digitally,
uh,
you,
you know,
I used to watch the old movies where cars would do,
uh,
you could tell the number of takes I by the skid marks on the road when they
would do a handbrake,
do you turn?
And you could see that,
you can see,
well,
now you can erase,
take one,
two,
three and use take forward.
And the same going across the desert.
You can erase that.
And most importantly,
you can put big harnesses on your stunt crew and your actors so that they would
be free to move on vehicles,
which are moving at speed and you know,
they're not going to fall to their death.
So that was a big deal.
And you could,
and you could erase the harnesses.
So that was a big deal.
Well that brings up a great point because I'm really interested in knowing,
cause you guys shot for about six months.
Was it right?
We shut for 138 days.
Okay.
That's,
I guess we were in the desert for,
um,
I think seven months.
Okay.
So you're there for seven months and practically some movies have like one or
maybe a handful of stones.
You,
I imagine have stands just about every day.
And so how are you able to manage and balance the,
the movie what you need to get,
what you want to get from,
you know,
a storyboard and script to safety and having all the,
the crews do it every single day.
That's,
that's,
that was the biggest issue for me.
And I think for everybody else,
um,
you,
you're out there and you know,
it's an arduous shoot.
Fatigue sets in.
It's,
it's,
uh,
you know,
by mid day gets very hot,
there's dust everywhere.
And,
um,
and every day is a big stunt day.
And,
and,
and w,
W,
W so you had to be immensely prepared.
We had a great stunt crew,
we had great stunt rigors,
uh,
and we are obsessed with safety,
a safety at all costs.
And,
and unless you do that,
you know,
the,
the moment you let your guard down,
even on something that seems relatively simple,
uh,
inevitably something can go wrong.
So you just really,
really have to,
you know,
we're very,
very mindful of that.
And,
and we,
you know,
and we came out without any broken limbs or,
there were bruises,
there are a couple of cuts there.
You know,
there were,
but nothing at all major.
Um,
and,
and that's partly,
you know,
people who are really determined not to have that happen.
And yet,
and yet,
um,
uh,
you know,
there was some things that we were able to do that I never imagined we could do.
Those guys on the Poles,
I always thought would be shot green screen and then we'd,
uh,
we'd,
we'd comp them into the vehicles moving underneath.
I thought it'd be too risky if something went wrong with one of those vehicles.
One of the benefits of the delays that the,
the stunt crew were able to work on them and work out a pendulum system.
Big,
big heavyweight underneath for those guys too,
you know.
And,
and one day I looked up and there they were coming through the desert,
so you know,
and,
and that it got so safe,
uh,
we were able to add some honey on top of one and that was really great.
It just feels more,
sorry,
how do you feel?
How do I,
well,
it wasn't until he got up there that he said,
Hey George,
I'm scared of heights.
And I thought,
well,
don't eat,
could we tried,
he wasn't joking,
he was scared of heights,
but he's very bright.
You know,
he got guys like,
he know he was a rugby player,
very athletic and very skilled at that sequential memory of,
of,
of events.
So the fights,
they're able to do work.
He worked very,
very well with us.
Stunt doubles and so on.
And the same as Shirley's.
She,
she,
having been an accomplished ballet dancer also had that,
that skillset.
So they were able to take on a huge amount.
Um,
and that was really great.
Yeah.
I mean the cast is phenomenal.
I kinda want to go back though to pay.
Um,
you didn't really start with a script.
You have to start with storyboards and you work with Brendan Mccarthy on this
and created basically the s two plus hour chasing and throughout the whole
movie.
But you didn't start with a script.
So that was,
I found that really interesting in terms of you visualize the entire movie and
kind of played it almost as a silent just action film versus,
Oh,
this with this character says here,
this is what this,
it was more visually telling the story.
Yes,
it does.
It for me,
you know,
have always been interested in and action cinema for a lot of reasons.
It's that cold movies,
uh,
you,
and,
and also I realized when I first got intrigued by making movies,
um,
I realized that most of this new language we call film language,
uh,
it,
it's only about 120 years old.
It's an acquired language and it's always evolving.
And most of it was defined pretty sound in the films of Buster Keaton and Harold
Lloyd and the two real westerns and Max sentence.
Uh,
they were essentially action movies.
So,
so for me,
this is like a silent movie with sound.
Obviously sound is incredibly critical in the storytelling and it's amazing how
even the subtlest of sound can change the experience.
But the basic form was a silent movie.
It could be if you were deaf,
uh,
you could still read this movie,
pretty well and not lose anything.
Um,
and,
uh,
so,
so the natural form of it was,
it was going to be in storyboards.
We did sort of
do a quick draft of the basic events that happened,
but it was in the storyboard where we defined as much as we could the characters
and the events and the design of the film.
Then when we had,
we ended up with 3,500 storyboards,
uh,
and then we,
and then we wrote a version before we,
which,
uh,
you know,
to the studios and so on also so that people can read it.
You can't,
it's very difficult to read storyboards because it misses the one important
dimension and that is time and rhythm.
But,
uh,
so we used to reading screenplays so that we,
we,
we had a kind of an illustrated screenplays illustrated by several panels of
storyboard and then basically set out in the more conventional way with dialogue
and some description.
One of the things I noticed,
I just watched the film again last night.
This is my fifth time and I'm obsessed with just the vehicles and the intention
that detail with everything.
And especially using,
you've used a lot of items that are very practical and even the set design and
the costumes and the vehicles that are almost,
yes,
of course his or be in a Po postflop Popkin apocalyptic world,
you know.
And so it was the flame throwing guitars using uh,
it looked like there was like a bed pan or something,
like all this crazy stuff.
And so can you talk about just the,
the real attention to detail.
Working with your set design has your vehicle designers and getting those
details in there.
It's very important when you're telling a story with just so helter skelter
kinetic that you,
that you have very,
very clear design principles.
If you're like,
uh,
everyone had to work to the same rule,
otherwise it would just be visual noise.
Um,
so,
so the kind of rules who work,
uh,
to,
that everything was basically found objects repurposed.
So if you notice that the mask that Max where's is made from a garden fork,
um,
uh,
the,
the vehicles had to be vehicles which didn't have the most modern technology
with microprocessors and crunch technology.
And so on and airbags because they wouldn't really survive anything with a
computer computer driven or the electric electricals are too complex or the
mechanics were too complex or sophisticated,
wouldn't have survived.
So it,
the vehicles had to be older.
Um,
every weapon,
if you look at the arm that Furiosa where's it's got,
it's got spanners and,
and stuff that you could find a,
as you say,
the,
the guitar double naked Tar.
It is,
part of it is a hospital bed pan.
It's made from a guitar and it's also Framestore are and,
and uh,
so everything had to work from that logic,
found objects and repurposed and it also included and then also applied to
costume and language.
If you look at the language of the film,
it was phrases that we might use and corrupted in some way.
A steering wheel,
um,
becomes a,
you know,
a semi religious artifact,
uh,
[inaudible] and uh,
so all of that sort of unified the film to some degree.
We were quite rigorous about those sorts of things.
The war rig was kind of a hybrid of,
of,
of of many things.
The,
the,
the importance,
uh,
we call it the Gig a horse was because it was like he's mobile throne.
He had the most resources,
so it's a double the Cadillac.
Um,
uh,
so we had to sort of follow that logic.
And the other thing we said,
um,
without going on too long,
we is,
we said that just because it's the wasteland,
it doesn't mean people can't make beautiful things and,
and,
and otherwise the whole thing.
We'd look like a junkyard.
And if you look at human behavior,
no matter how he impoverished or limited in our resources,
even early Paleolithic man could do beautiful cave drawings and,
and,
and carvings and so on.
And so,
so if you had something you and you had the time yet,
you'd have to make it as beautiful as you could or interestingly,
she could,
which is driving,
what were you thinking of all this is going to be an awesome start.
Let's build a vehicle for it.
Where were you building the vehicles and being like,
oh,
I got some crazy shit.
Let's just take this guy.
And you know,
it actually,
it was much more story driven.
Um,
uh,
the stents came out of story.
Uh,
you,
you had to decide,
for instance,
it was really interesting stuff.
We had a hot rod or rusted hot Rod,
which flips at one point,
and they were attacked by the spiky cars,
which we call buzzards.
Um,
and,
and we thought,
well,
okay,
how would they stop a vehicle if they're basically ha scavenging anyone who
dared to come into their territory?
And,
um,
and we thought,
okay,
there might build a kind of trap that's triggered by some sort of cable.
And,
and,
uh,
we,
we start to play with that stunt and we did a rehearsal with the stunt with,
uh,
with,
you know,
sacrificial vehicle.
And we found the way that stuck was constructed that if we did it right,
the car would flip in that interesting way,
particularly if it was this hot rod.
So when it came out of story,
everything came out of story.
Uh,
and that would lead to the stunt,
the guys on the Poles.
Um,
you know,
it's like pirates having to board a well defended a war rig,
which just carrying all this cargo had he get on board.
If there's spikes on it,
you can't approach it from the ground.
Let's see if they can approach it from above.
And then you say,
and then you say,
okay,
maybe we can have these guys on Poles.
Uh,
uh,
I don't think the stents came.
I can't think of an example where a stunt came first.
Uh,
always arose out of story or the events.
Yeah.
Um,
and I want to talk about Charlie's,
their rounds Furiosa character because she was by far,
I think one of the coolest characters I've ever seen on screen in the past few
decades.
It just very powerful and strong,
actually very much surprise me because it's a mad max movie.
But you have this amazing female world warrior.
And I heard that you brought in a eve Ensler who read the vagina monologues and
to kind of help her and help with the five wives who were basically like,
I guess the cargo,
the whole film of them,
kind of chasing them down to give them some speeches about empowering them and
how they should be acting and really kind of building them up to,
to build up their characters.
So can you talk about that?
Well,
Eh,
the Ozo always interested in a female road warrior.
Uh,
it goes in the CIC and Medmax of road,
the road warrior [inaudible].
There was a warrior woman in that who appeared briefly and was killed during
that.
Always wondered,
you know,
how,
how does she become that,
uh,
the story required once,
once,
once we,
you know,
I realize that the basic McGuffin,
the thing that everyone was fighting over was going to be human.
It was five females.
They needed a female champion of female road warrior.
So,
so the very mechanics of the story required furious.
Someone like Furiosa and the idea was as always,
Max get swept in to that story rather reluctantly.
So.
So with her [inaudible] she was,
she was written that way and then he,
he was an actor.
Charlene,
she's the only,
but anyone who ever came to mind and,
uh,
and,
and you,
she has that skill set.
She,
and she had the appetite to do it.
She's the one who said,
hey,
listen,
she wouldn't mess with her hair.
She,
so she just says,
I shave it off.
And I said,
by all means,
and uh,
and it was exactly the right thing to do.
Interestingly enough,
there was backstory,
which we talked around,
uh,
you know,
around the table and,
and she knew eve and,
and,
and you know,
there's work with her on one of her boards in Africa because eve does epic work,
therefore women in Democratic Republic of Congo among other places.
But interesting.
Lee enough.
So Elise did the same sort of training as the war boys.
We had military guys and,
and so because she was a warrior,
a eve mainly mainly worked with the five wives and,
and Miss Giddy,
the history of woman who is their mentor and because they needed some,
some something to give them some cohesion as well,
some shared world.
So I know Charlene dipped into it a bit,
but her main thing was to learn how to shoot,
shoot and how to drive.
Uh,
she,
she already could drive a big rig,
but she could,
I don't think she did done much shooting and uh,
and obviously fight rehearsal and so on,
which was very balletic and,
and she took on a lot of that.
So,
so she,
yeah,
she was,
she was more warrior workshop that then let's say feminists work shall,
it wasn't really feminist works on,
I mean it was mainly talking about a lot about history and,
and seeing how in some places in the world,
uh,
people in a lot of places in the world,
people are commodities.
Yeah.
And you,
uh,
so casting Tom Hardy,
you know,
that was,
I was interesting cause you had to basically replace someone to reprise the role
of Mad Max for Mel Gibson.
So what drew you to Tom Hardy and at what place was he,
did he come into the process at some point you basically realize that we can't
use Melanie Moore.
Yeah.
Mill way back in 2000,
we were going to shoot with mill and that's when,
uh,
and then the film first filled out,
but for the first time,
uh,
with when non living came along and we had lost almost a third of our budget of
a notch with the American dollar collapsed against the Australian dollar.
So when,
until other things,
and then when we regroup Millie Owlette turbulence and his life,
and also as time was passing,
it's not a kind of unforgiving about an old,
older warrior.
So thinking back to earlier days,
Max is still this,
every man wandering,
wandering the wasteland in search of meaning.
And Tom Walked through the door and,
uh,
and he felt exactly,
I felt exactly the same feeling that I felt about Mel Gibson when he walked
through the door 30 years before.
And,
and Tom was six weeks old when,
when we shot the first mode back when we started first mad max,
he was such a baby.
Um,
and,
and then he had that same energy immediately likable union.
There was that sort of danger of volcanic quality.
And also both of them were creatures of the theater,
the theater to train
Mel and Tom.
And,
uh,
even though melt was straight out of drama school,
spent a lot of time at national drum drum school in,
in Sydney,
Australia,
you know,
doing Shakespeare and,
and,
uh,
and he almost literally went from Romeo in Romeo,
Juliet one day to mad max the next.
Um,
and,
but they had that,
that quality.
They're both very athletic and,
and also they're able to,
you know,
when,
when he get all that energy,
that pent up energy and asking them to play a still character is very laconic.
Uh,
it's,
it's much more,
it's much more interesting.
So that's how Tom,
you brought back here to be the main villain of the story.
He played toe cutter and,
and the first series.
So yeah.
What was that idea of like your hunger and bringing it back,
but you going to be a completely different character and he's going to be crazy?
Well,
a huge case.
Boone is a really interesting guy.
Um,
he,
he's from at British military family and he was the first in about four
generations.
That is,
he says,
rent away to become an actor.
And he joined the Royal Shakespeare Company,
uh,
and travel the world with very celebrated production of midsummer night's dream.
I by Peter Brook,
they led,
they ended in Australia and they formed a commune of actors in Sydney.
And,
uh,
he,
he was just fantastic and I didn't know much about acting at all.
Uh,
uh,
back when we did the first mad max and,
and,
and one way or another,
uh,
um,
we,
we couldn't afford to fly.
He's a good can we use all the guys I work with?
I said,
well,
we,
we can't afford to fly everyone down.
Her budget was so low that we couldn't have flight,
uh,
four to fly them all down to Melbourne.
We should have cost Melbourne actors.
And he said,
well,
what about you?
Put the motorbikes on the train and send it up to Sydney and we'll ride the
bikes down.
Well,
it was just fantastic because by the time they spent three days writing down
about six,
seven,
eight of them,
and by the time they travel,
the 900 miles,
whatever it was,
uh,
they,
they were a biking gang and,
and they would come onto set and would get nervous.
It was just such a wonderful thing and it really added a lot to help help
everybody with the shoot.
And,
and then the Tokata character dies at the end of that movie.
and,
and I thought,
well,
we can bring him back and he'll wear a mask,
the whole movie.
Anyway,
he's got fantastic eyes and,
and sure enough,
all these years later,
uh,
the Joe huge w walk under sending costume.
And he did insist that not only the stunt guys,
and not only the war boy actors,
but even the crew do the sign of the VA aid and,
and call him daddy.
And,
and it was fantastic.
You know,
he,
he very playful and,
but,
but in the way I really bought into it and made it sort of fun and,
and,
and uh,
you know,
people really got into it.
It was fantastic.
So he's one of those actors that brings,
brings a lot with him.
Uh,
he was phenomenal and we killed him off in this movie
spot.
Um,
so we have some questions that we gathered from the toxic Google social media.
And so one of the top ones actually came in a lot was there was talk at some
point from you about a black and white version of this and possibly even a sound
version of this.
So is there any hope for that?
Well,
way back in road warrior,
the best version I have,
a sort of road warrior was when the composers in those days when they can
conduct in the orchestra,
we'd get the answer print,
which is colored.
And they do what they call a slash June,
which is a very cheap,
high contrast,
black and white print of the film.
And they'd put their markings on there and they'd conduct to this version.
And I remember walking in the first day,
uh,
and looking at the road warrior and thinking,
wow,
that's how the film should look.
It's just something about black and white distills and abstracts the image and
forces,
the,
the kind of almost mythological,
sort of allegorical quality of the story.
So,
um,
when we came to do this movie,
I remember telling the wonderful color,
colorist Eric Whip,
uh,
you know,
can you take that scene and just make it high contrast,
black and white,
particularly the outdoor scenes.
And it looked fantastic.
And I said,
and I said,
okay,
we'll,
we'll do version two to almost almost hop back to the old silent era.
And we'll do a version which just shows you can watch it completely solid.
We can watch it black and white with just the music score,
or you can watch it black and white with just the sound and to compare it.
But by the time we do blueray went there wasn't room for to,
to put her on another disk.
But definitely hope to do that in the future because there's something about it
and you know,
you take a picture on your smartphone and then you just make it black and white.
And if somehow just cooler.
I don't know why I still,
I think it's the abstraction.
It takes out information and,
and maybe gives it a more timeless quality color,
often
sort of anchor something in time.
I don't know what it is.
It might be just a nostalgia for the black and white movies or black and white
photography.
But somehow this,
this,
this movie looked cool.
And another one from social is what was the most difficult scene to shoot
because it looked like the entire film.
What is it difficult?
The entire,
sometime it's the littlest things.
It can drive you nuts.
Uh,
um,
you know,
it like literally,
um,
uh,
you know,
there's the shot of a little bird made up of bolts and parts of a vehicle and it
was just nodding its head.
And I remember the last day,
um,
uh,
great props guy,
George Samaj and,
and,
and the script supervisors,
Sophie would determined to get those shots and,
uh,
we were racing to finish and,
and had little silhouette why I sought it and moving it.
And it was,
it was difficult to get it moving properly and get the,
the,
you know,
the background movie.
But for me personally,
um,
the,
uh,
the guys on the Poles,
initially I thought it would be difficult,
uh,
but as it,
as it turned out,
that was okay.
But for me,
I'd say the most difficult thing was the war rig flipping at the end.
Because initially I thought,
oh,
too much energy in that tea.
Too many,
too,
too much to too much mass to put a human being in there.
I'm just a bit worried about it.
And then we thought we'd do it a CG,
but that was sort of cheating given that we've shot the rest of the movie.
Everything was real.
Then we thought of doing it with a miniature,
but they don't work very well in daylight because of dust and so on.
You see,
you see it miniatures,
just the,
just the physics of it doesn't work.
Then we thought of doing it with a remote control vehicle and a w w w w we
could,
we could control it accurately mean we couldn't flip it.
And it had to go between two big massive rocks and it had to land in front of
our Phantom Camera,
which is running at about six or 700 frames a,
I mean,
and,
um,
and that suites what was going to be difficult.
So,
so,
you know,
and,
and then it rained and,
and anyway,
Lee hours and had a great,
great driver.
Uh,
uh,
there's a break in the rain.
And,
uh,
we did this shot and,
and he had the sweet spot and we only had one tank.
So,
um,
so that Wa I remember that,
uh,
I a new week prepared enough for him to be safe,
but something can always go wrong.
But the fact that he actually landed it right there in front of the key camera,
we had lots of other cameras,
but he wanted to hit that sweet spot.
Said that that was just technically that was difficult.
Yeah.
I love that you pushed for it and just say,
we're not changing,
like this is going to happen.
And that's,
it's,
it's phenomenal because it shows on screen.
I mean,
that Labor of love and that,
yeah,
we,
well,
as I said,
we had people who really as hot as it was,
they would determine to get it right.
We had gotten Norris,
who was the hitch,
Doug Co,
Co Coordinator and second unit director,
and he was a 21 year old.
His first film was on fury road,
Warrior back.
I'm not a 90,
90,
90.
I think we shot on 91.
And,
uh,
and,
and he'd,
you know,
he,
he was,
he just kept saying,
look,
we could do it.
We can do it.
And,
uh,
it was great.
It was great to see,
um,
you know,
Furiosa again,
she's just a phenomenal character.
And so one of the questions someone had was,
is there a version of her backstory that you can tell us or he's still saving
that I'm saving,
we're saving them.
And then I know the backstory for,
uh,
I would say Nico Service and I who,
who,
who also came into right after Brendan and may need to go down and he's
basically a Dramaturg and we'd go down deep into the backstory,
you know,
I know,
I know who the due for his mother was.
I know how a man who's blind and mute,
uh,
and can only play a guitar,
survived the apocalypse and managed to,
you know,
make me,
uh,
so you have to know the backstory of everything and certainly we know your yeses
and we know Max what happened in Mexico in the meantime,
and how each of the wives got there and so on.
But,
uh,
yeah,
for another time.
Yeah.
Um,
so audience questions from Googlers.
Yeah.
One of the unusual things about Max compared to the current crop of action
movies is that it's an original world and original stories created just for the
movies.
I'm kind of curious how much you think that has to do with kind of know the
experience of writing and directing or like the quality of the movies.
Mostly like whether you know,
whether you think it's,
that makes it easier to make a high quality movie.
Um,
I'm also curious if you think we're doomed.
It just an endless string of adaptations,
mostly in a,
all the other franchises.
Ooh.
Um,
that's,
um,
look,
uh,
it's a tough business.
The movie business,
um,
Eh,
to do original work.
W W W we're seeing,
you know,
reboots and sequels and,
and,
and that,
that's,
that comes and goes with cinema.
If you,
if you look at early cinema,
they were always,
um,
you know,
the first time I ever saw Clint Eastwood in a movie,
it was on TV.
Was it,
Eh,
uh,
the movie's called Francis,
the talking mule movies.
And if you look at one of those,
this one called Francis goes to the navy.
And in the background,
a young,
Tall Sila in the group of silence,
that easy hung out with,
I think it was done a lot of Kona.
We make him laugh from,
um,
from singing in the right.
He,
he this Clint Eastwood and there was several,
Francis and Francis the talking mule movies and I think that should be the
nature of cinnamon.
I think a lot of that was,
was,
uh,
in response to the advent of television and,
and,
and so it was cinema scope and so it was three d stereo.
And so that's,
the movies are always having to adapt in that way.
I think that's what we're seeing.
If your first question was,
do you think it's,
it,
it's useful that,
that,
that there's some are writing,
directing and producing and making the film so that they're more go here and I,
I,
I'd say that has to be an advantage.
Um,
um,
yeah.
I mean these characters live and this world lives in,
in your head,
like imaginary friends and they pop up from time to time and you keep saying,
I don't want to do,
I don't want to go back there again.
And then suddenly a story takes hole and you feel a kind of gravitational pull
towards a story and you just get to the point where he just can't wait to see if
he can pull it off and see it up there on the screen.
So I guess it's an advantage.
Yeah.
Okay.
You mentioned,
uh,
about the fact of the store over the characters keep on living in your head,
and uh,
and it takes you,
it took you awhile to figure out,
uh,
but you have this new story that you want to tell us.
So I was wondering what exactly was it?
At what point exactly did you,
uh,
decide that you'll have something that you want to develop into the next movie?
Well,
it's,
it's an interesting thing because I remember
thinking,
well,
I'll back up.
Story is what really is the primary driving force,
uh,
at bench.
It's usually supported by,
uh,
an interest in the tools so that,
um,
for instance,
I really like the story,
the natural history of the emperor penguins.
And I had the story and it wasn't till,
uh,
Andrew Leslie,
the wonderful cameraman who shopped the babe movies had just come back from the
first Lord of the rings and showed me the,
the first motion capture of Gollum.
I realized,
Oh,
motion capture dancing penguins.
So that was,
that was,
that was the,
there has to be some,
something technical that,
that's interesting.
So the first idea for fury road,
uh,
was,
was to see whether he could tell almost a continuous chase and picking up
everything on the run and see if he could pick up any,
your backstories characters such suggested,
uh,
you know,
a lot of iceberg under the tip,
as I like to say.
Uh,
that was the first exercise.
And the second one was that what they were,
what they were in conflict over was to be human,
human cargo.
So five women.
And,
and that was,
that was the first thing.
And,
and then I,
you know,
I had,
I did forcibly pushed the idea of way,
but,
but as often happens,
it just stated,
and I,
and,
and without going too long a story,
I was flying one night from Los Angeles across the Pacific to Sydney.
And in an unguarded moment,
much of the first two thirds of the story played out because I'd been doing this
for so long now,
scenes play out in my head.
And,
uh,
it played out and I got really excited.
Ooh,
that would work.
That would work,
man,
Max and get caught up up in it.
And I remember landing in Sydney,
interlink telling my producing partner,
Doug Mitchell,
I think there's another mad max movie.
Uh,
and um,
and,
uh,
so yeah,
so it's,
and then there's that feeling,
oh Jeez.
It'd be really good to try that.
And we could use,
you know,
we could,
I really always wanted to do stereo three d we can do,
it's three day.
We could use,
uh,
you know,
digital.
The digital dispensation had,
had arrived and learned quite a bit about it on the bay movies.
And,
uh,
I thought,
oh,
we could do so much more that we couldn't do back in the day.
So that's,
I hope that answers the question.
I wanted to ask about the baby movies.
Actually two has been called the citizen Kane of talking pig movies.
This similarity of world building for something like extending babe into the
beauty that is picking the city to something like extending Mad Max.
Can you talk about the kind of the creative similarity and difference of just
kind of that universe Belding
well,
um,
I think,
I think it's important.
Uh,
it's what I think is what I was trying to get at before you see these films that
Alec,
Greece and you,
you trying to create worlds and,
and the film was you don't have time to sit and explain the details of the world
or how they came about because you're kind of working off of what's already
there and the zeitgeists and you're also working on a,
an all that came before it all traditions of storytelling,
uh,
history,
you know,
mythology,
folk lore,
comic books,
it,
all of that.
Uh,
and when you're in,
in both those cases,
uh,
you,
you basically,
the most important thing is don't,
it is not to spend all your time or wasting too much time with exposition
because it's very hard to dramatize you.
You have to dramatize your exposition,
but it's like inviting into a world that is on the one hand unique and yet
familiar.
So to get that balance right and the best way to get that balance right,
I find is to be rigorous as much as possible about the internal logic.
Um,
that,
that it's there.
A conceits in the movie,
like animals talk,
embrace them,
declare the [inaudible],
don't apologize or explain them,
but,
but be consistent.
Um,
uh,
if it's in the design of the world of the buildings and there's a certain
aesthetic,
be consistent.
Uh,
and that means really,
really tried to,
tried to define what's important.
And then,
uh,
making sure that everyone that's involved in the design,
that we're all following the same sort of rules.
We're all working to the same principles.
And that's what I described before about the,
the vehicles or the,
you know,
I didn't,
I didn't think of that garden fork on Max's face.
I love that.
But it was a pull Jayco designer from England,
uh,
W who is,
who is,
who did it.
And,
uh,
and we,
we had some early designs,
which just as kind of a bit of a mosque or muscle or a Cajun,
he just suddenly send us a drawing with gotten folk.
I think it's great.
It's exactly what we want.
And,
uh,
and I didn't come up with the idea of the guitar having a hospital bed pan in
it,
um,
or,
or a good,
or a steering wheel with a,
with a,
um,
uh,
the Nexia steering wheel,
which he holds up with,
with adults face and,
and,
and so on that,
that,
that was,
uh,
you know,
the,
that was the artist who,
who's making the steering wheel B.
But in each of those cases,
people knew it had to be found objects repurposed.
So,
uh,
the,
the Morton's mosque,
it was basically so that he can,
he needed a blender so he could breathe.
Um,
really,
uh,
you know,
relatively fresh filtered air,
we assume.
Um,
but,
uh,
but it couldn't look therapeutic.
And it also had to look for minimal after all,
he was supposed to be this old powerful Demi God warlord.
So the horses teeth and all of that was built,
built into it,
and it would apply to the vehicles.
And as some of those were pretty Atlanta outlandish,
but,
but they had to,
had to be consistent in their logic.
Uh,
that big double Cadillac,
um,
uh,
was,
was the most powerful man's vehicle.
Uh,
the guys who had flame throwers with a gap from gas town.
So they had a lot that they had those flame throwers.
Uh,
the guy with the most guns and bullets was the bullet farmer from the bullet
farm.
Uh,
the,
the doof warrior was the equivalent of all military,
um,
uh,
armies.
All the armies that were,
uh,
pre,
which predated,
uh,
the,
the ability to amplify sound.
So you have the Bugler,
the drummer,
the Bagpipe player,
and in this world with all those hot cars and making lot of noise,
you needed something louder.
So he needed the big speakers.
You needed a double neck guitar and you needed to Tyco dramas.
It had to follow a logic.
It just couldn't be plunked in there without some consistency.
And the hope is that,
uh,
even the tattoos,
the marking,
there's a logic to why Furiosa has a mark,
you know,
Mark's her body in a certain way as compared to knucks.
Um,
the spraying of,
of the silver.
We had to have an internal logic that had to be consistent and anything that's
straight out of those boundary conditions usually bought you out of that,
out of the movie.
So it looks pretty wild and abandoned,
but there's some sort of method in the madness.
Uh,
you
mentioned earlier about,
um,
sometimes story and tools,
interest in tools go hand in hand.
And you talked earlier about how the number of cuts have increased in movies in
general.
I was wondering if you felt a normative kind of feeling towards whether that's a
good thing or a bad thing or is that just a thing?
And also,
sorry,
the last part of this question is,
I assume you shot some of the action sequences with multiple cameras.
So how did you justify when to cut?
Um,
and were you trying intentionally to create some type of frenetic nature with
your cuts?
Or was it like the whole conversation around cuts?
I'm just curious,
what's your take on that?
I don't think it's necessarily a good thing or bad thing.
It's a,
it's a thing and you can do movies.
Um,
uh,
we would not have any cuts at all and it's still have a strong rhythm and so on.
And there's really good examples,
uh,
of those,
one shot scenes in a movie like this.
Uh,
I was always struck by Roman Polanski's a statement where he said,
at any given moment there's only one perfect place for the camera in a movie and
doing animations,
you can always prove that because you could move the camera anywhere you like.
And it does exactly the same performance and same,
same sets and same blocking and everything.
And by shifting point of view and cutting pattern,
you can change a sing significantly.
The feeling of the same.
The cutting is,
isn't is another issue.
I,
uh,
work with Margaret [inaudible] who is also my life's partner.
And,
and,
and she said,
she,
she's cut quite a bit,
uh,
documentaries and she,
and she cut the first happy feed and,
and,
and she said,
well,
you know,
I'm not that into action movies.
It's not something that go out of my way,
even though we have teenage sons.
It's not something we go out of our way to that she would go out of a way to
look at.
And I said,
well,
that's the very reason because you will shoot,
she's done a lot of medical documentaries and things and somehow can take very
dry material and structure it dramatically.
And,
and it's something that I notice is very,
uh,
it's very difficult to do.
It's not just taking the next cool shot or an or and putting in there and
keeping a certain pace going.
Um,
it's,
it,
it's very,
very similar to writing music.
It is visual music and the,
the,
the one thing that you're always striving for it that she would do intuitively
would find a very,
very powerful,
a causal relationship.
One shot to the next,
uh,
it might be pure framing and I scan,
it might be the manic,
it might be just
it,
it spatial usually,
but there had to be in the same way that a composer is looking at code structure
or tempo or,
or,
um,
in a melodic line or whenever there's almost a mathematical basis to,
to,
to music.
Uh,
it's almost like that in,
in cutting,
uh,
it's something that people only experience in the cutting room.
And when he confronted by footage and she had to take that on and she's one of
those editors,
I'm not good with my hands on the extras and so on,
but I'm pretty good on carts.
But she could see cuts,
not cuts with,
see a progression of shots or cuts away to make cuts than I couldn't say.
But it was always underpinned by that.
Looking for that strong connection between one shot,
the other usually as simple as where I scan,
uh,
and,
and how you basically,
uh,
how the inflammation I'm falls in what order.
There's one particular bit of information,
uh,
come when do you need it?
And when,
you know,
how do you,
how do you make it clear to the audience where you are?
And then,
and then looking at the temper of the shots.
Um,
and she also has a very low boredom threshold.
So no repetition,
uh,
even repetition of angles.
I mean,
it could get very boring bunch of people sitting in a vehicle,
uh,
with very limited shots.
They're sitting down,
they're not moving it.
It happens over three days,
two nights scenes.
But you know,
it could get very boring.
So you always gotta be looking for ways to have more information in each,
in each shop.
It must in some way progress the character or the relationship between character
or the progression of the story in some way.
So all of these things are dancing around in the back of your brain,
and intuitively you're looking for those sort of moments,
which,
which come forward.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Thank you so much for being here.
Um,
thank you.
Mad Max fury road is out now on Blu ray and on digital on Google place.
So thank you so much for being here.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
[inaudible].